the corona virus outbreak hit people
across the world claiming too many lives
it infected the very roots of our
economy and raised many questions about
our healthcare systems and this first
episode of what's left we take a closer
look at the spread of the crisis to the
economy just bad omen Canada's economy
wheat on its major c'mon that yoga to
shun geometrician see what nationally
this crisis might just be the
opportunity to rethink Europe's current
economic model and here's how
[Music]
as country starting on finding one after
the other economic figures are out and
they're not reassuring the global freeze
of the economy a first in modern history
is set to cause the eurozone to contract
by 7.5 percent this year
the worst recession since the Great
Depression danke Napa they done back so
this epidemic lasing don't let that
he-she I mean I just read on the mouth
from the mouth of an ashram if you like
ease yourself kiss give especially
uphill goofy no
the jobs of up to fifty nine million
people in Europe are at risk that's
almost the entire population of France
beyond the numbers we are talking about
the livelihoods of citizens their
incomes and their plans for the future
that would put in question overnight
there are legislative and budgetary
actions by member states since the
beginning of the crisis however these
measures will affect unevenly member
states due to the different spread of
the virus but also to the different
structure of the economy of those states
it took a month of confinement before EU
leaders finally took action as one
United block a common bazooka package
amounting to 540 billion euros was
agreed on in April to protect workers
businesses and countries Western actress
European only single Astarte recommittal
Eva from data he's so close to Queen D
devarakonda visa in the longer term all
EU countries will need cash to face the
economy consequences of the crisis in
other words finance a massive recovery
plan if we take a look at history we may
find some clues to figure out what to do
next in the 1930s to pull his country
out of the depression Rousseff L decided
to take radical measures he tripled the
federal budget in a few years creating
new resources putting in place a federal
tax on profits and on the richest the
first year it didn't work out
Gru's weld emitted bonds for a few years
and with a massive stimulus package his
tax plan paid
for today's progressives this president
in history could give us a way out one
tool governments have in their toolbox
to finance their actions in addition to
taxation is that in normal times all
European countries can issue bonds to
borrow money on the financial markets
but at some point those countries will
have to reimburse the money if financial
markets trust your country they will
lend money easily at low interest rates
Lackey's not say tada yeah dpq might
push to chick Dodd said Chris sanitaire
include a GDP control approach to the
code but for other countries that don't
look quite as stable interest rates can
rise this has a tremendous impact on the
country's ability to restore its
economic strength what might seem like a
pretty insignificant rise in interest
rates can quite quickly turn into
billions of euros to be paid back ESCO
control notice it can be reduced to
Chicago not arbitrated the public
control cell epistemology is a mechanism
a Dimitra body on an aphasic national TV
Abinadi GDP repetition is a mechanism
adhere to the mildest suited item
vaccine we notice variety in order to
avoid this competition between states
and make sure we have a truly solidarity
based recovery progressives in the
European Parliament but the idea issuing
corona bonds at the European level on
the table in other words a common
European debt
check B Yahoo hey psychopathy in on this
mom new hopper she knows evil power come
releasing the children mia cowan up once
a year now this is a bastard Montoya yes
honey they're just go support
non-silicon whole awesome if the EU
jointly borrows money on the financial
markets it also needs to be able to
jointly pay back money borrowed the
progressives are pushing to create new
own resources for the EU budget to
create in Devon in revenue for the EU
asking for fee on unrecycled Plastics
drawing resources from the European
emission straight system raising income
taxes on big corporates creating a
digital services tax but he can place a
tax on financial transactions while
making sure the revenues from tax
avoidance and tax evasion go where the
money is needed
[Music]
a few weeks into confinement people woke
up to a world where the air was clean
and where traffic wasn't a nuisance any
more spectacular drops in co2 emissions
were observed
but this doesn't give us the bigger
picture in the last year co2 emissions
have risen more rapidly than in the 60s
and 70s from 0.8 units to two Pranay per
year temperatures continue to rise
everywhere and whether it are needed to
deal with the situation individual
health mwah you look happy
imagine a something absolutely ma with
imagining losses so now we do be news as
well a cookie na na [ __ ] nobuta do not
be in a facility gravity is familiar
phenol so sorry therapy so how do we do
it how do we protect citizens jobs and
livelihoods while addressing the biggest
challenge Humanity has probably ever had
to face for the socialists and Democrats
the path is clear it's called the green
new deal with a just transition at its
heart to ensure that no one is left
behind when we rebuild our economies and
our societies on a sustainable basis and
we did you were lost it will transform
and strong its thank me or not so we can
get a better you clima
develop our commonality in the end
progressive ideas caught the
Commission's ear and by the end of May
it propose the comprehensive recovery
plan seven hundred and fifty billion
euros to support the plucks economies
these investments would come on top of
an existing one point one trillion euro
wide budgetary plan the hardest hit
sectors and the most affected regions
must be provided with a lifeline to
ensure they don't have to fight workers
or close down before recovery kicks in
the SMD group will continue putting
pressure on EU leaders so that Europe
can live up to its ambitions
siamo since eros el problema no es poner
meses de niro
el problema es have Ansari nirupa
signora von der Leyen
Java Stoke aqui en el parliamentary
opieop en
un proyecto despues tow trabajar siempre
por el bien de la ciudad ania hora
le toka combin serve a los amigos del
consejo Saluda vamos a las próximas
genera fiona's de la la ropa
with the coronavirus crisis we've all
been left in a state of shock first and
foremost was protecting people's health
supporting the most vulnerable in
society and ensuring that workers will
have a job to return to after the end of
the outbreak but then we also woke up to
a new world of possibilities working
from home experimenting new forms of
solidarity and when the clapping stops
and when bit by bit that sense of
normality comes back into our lives what
will we do
will we go back to our old ways or will
we embrace real change in this crisis
the progressives will have fought and
pushed for a real change refusing to sit
on the sidewalk of history while
watching workers businesses and our
planet go bust now it is time to be bold
and innovative and build a better future
for all stay tuned for next episode of
what's left where we will explore in
more depth how tomorrow's world could
look like
[Music]